ça paraît pas bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors 20 ans après cette catastrophe le
bilan est sans appel puisque le pays est
aujourd'hui à la dérive
la moitié de la population vit sous le
seuil de la pauvreté les libanais qui
attendent des réponses que justice soit
faite
quel est le sentiment qui règne
aujourd'hui au liban de la colère de
l'amertume de la tristesse
alors oui évidemment il ya beaucoup de
tristesse quand même c'est un c'est un
traumatisme très violente qu'on subit
des libanais ya un an et est aujourd'hui
on sent toute cette tristesse remonter
un mais elle a aussi beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de colère parce que un an plus
tard vous l'avez dit il enquête piétine
les questions restent nombreuses
alors ce qu'on sait le plus si la piste
il ya trois volets dans l' enquête alors
il ya pourquoi 2007 150 tonnes de
nitrates sont arrivés au port de
beyrouth
est-ce que c'était parce que au départ
normalement cette cargaison était
destinée vers le mozambique il est alors
effet un passage par beyrouth pour
charger une marchandise et finalement se
seraient retrouvés bloqués là donc là il
ya beaucoup de questions qui persistent
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas ce que
c'est accidentel ou est ce que
finalement sur les traces étaient
destinés à beyrouth avec éventuellement
des questions sur est ce qu'il n'aurait
pas été utilisé en syrie notamment sur
ce volet là on sait rien pour le moment
c'est pourquoi ce nitrates s'est
retrouvé à beyrouth il ya le deuxième
volet qui et comment sonitra de se
retrouver stockés dans des conditions
lamentables pendant sept ans alors la
sarre oui ça met en lumière on ne voit
bien la responsabilité de beaucoup de
fonctionnaires
au déduisent ont été inculpées une
trentaine de personnes de d'employés du
port de beyrouth des douanes ont été
inculpées vingtaine sont en état de
détention
dès aujourd'hui il apparaît clairement
que l'information est remonté dans la
hiérarchie que tout le monde savait
jusqu'au chef de l'état qui lui même a
reçu un rapport quelques mois avant
l'explosion indiquant clairement les
risques des ministres des hauts
responsables sécuritaires un ancien chef
de l'armée
enfin des gens qu'ils étaient très haut
placé et qui ont qui n'ont rien fait
pour prévenir la catastrophe
jusqu au procureur de la république dont
qui a été mis au courant des conditions
lamentables dans lequel étaient stockés
cette allemagne homme et tout ce qu'il a
ordonné ces des travaux de soudure va
les travaux pour sécuriser
si vous voulez le hangar et non pas de
déplacer cette matière explosive qui
était mise dans une zone résidentielle
et donc comporter des risques énormes
donc il ya tout ce volet de négligence
d'homicide involontaire si vous voulez
dire responsabilité des responsables
libanais de tous bords de hauts
responsables de libanais alors ça ça
commence à être clairement mis en
évidence même si pour l'instant on n'a
pas encore lu l'acte d'accusation
mais les rapports de human rights watch
appelle toutes les informations qui ont
fuité montrent clairement que pendant
sept ans tout le monde a échoué tout le
monde savait alors ça c'est une
certitude aujourd'hui tout le monde
toute la hiérarchie savait même si
aujourd'hui sur jeu de la responsabilité
certains affirment qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas la dangerosité et
l'autre que c'était pas leurs
prérogatives en fait tout le monde se
défile de sa responsabilité n'est
clairement aujourd'hui tout le système
tous les hauts responsables savaient
qu'il y avait de 1700 tonnes de un
explosif très dangereux entreposés au
port de beyrouth
et puis enfin il ya le dernier volet de
l'enquète qui est qu'est-ce qui a
provoqué l'incendié qu'est ce qui a
provoqué l explosion ça aussi on n'en
sait pas plus mais pour l'instant le
juge a donc demandé à des hauts
responsables à demander la levée
immunitaire de hauts responsables pour
pouvoir les les interpeller et
évidemment il s'est heurté au parlement
et à toute la classe politique qui
malgré tous ces discours disant on veut
on veut la justice on veut que justice
soit faite en réalité s'oppose
farouchement à l'avancé parce que ça les
impliquerait tous de tous bords et qu'
ils ont pas envie de 2,2
de montrer à quel point ils sont ils
sont irresponsables et à quel point ils
ont été coupables de négligence ce
criminel à l'égard ils ont été
incapables politique
on va en parler puisque depuis ce drame
on voit qu'il ya une crise concernant
justement les gouvernements plusieurs
premiers ministres se sont succédé aucun
n'a réussi à former justement un
gouvernement pour remettre le liban sur
pied la nomination de najib mikati
peut-elle changer quelque chose
la communauté internationale aussi qui
tentent de faire pression justement pour
pour qu'un gouvernement soit formé
alors la nomination de la gym et ati et
n'est évidemment pas une solution
puisque najib mikati était lui-même
d'ailleurs premier ministre à l'époque
où le loup neutre at est rentré à
beyrouth il fait partie du système
il est certain c'est un cacique du de la
classe politique
donc non il ne répond à la revendication
des libanais qui réclame vraiment un
changement de système une autre façon de
gouverner qui réclamait un gouvernement
transitoire avec des pouvoirs
législatifs or aujourd'hui on prend les
mêmes et on recommence quelles que
soient les membres de ce gouvernement
la façon dont on nomme les membres du
co2 de ce gouvernement le parlement
enfin tout est encore contrôler le
système n'a pas bougé malgré la violence
de la crise et continuent à s'accrocher
au pouvoir et aujourd'hui dans la sphère
du port dans laquelle sa responsabilité
est clairement établie ils essaient ils
essayent de se défiler ils accusent la
justice d'être politisé alors que c'est
eux mêmes qui ont qui ont politisé la
justice pendant toutes ces années et
encore essayer de perpétuer ce cette
culture de l'impunité qui est très
existantes au liban et qui consiste à
dire en oublions le passé et passe à
autre chose
mais les libanais ne veulent plus
injustement ils n'en peuvent plus de
drames de traumatismes de douleur pour
lequel personne n'est jamais responsable
et aujourd'hui réclame que les
responsabilités soient est clairement
établie et que les quelques coupables
payent le prix de l'heure de leur quine
donc à voir aujourd'hui l'arrêt en
libanais justement de tourner la page d'
essayer de se reconstruire
c'est nécessaire la justice est
nécessaire pour les pour les victimes
pour tout le pays qui qui qui subi coup
sur coup depuis deux ans qu'ils aient
perpétré dans une crise sans précédent
et kiwi a besoin comme moi et c'est là
mais pareil pour la crise économique
pour la crise financière pour toutes les
crises il n'y a jamais de responsables
au liban parce que les responsables sont
irresponsables parce que le système fait
en sorte que la responsabilité soit
constamment diluée et donc personne de
la porte qu'il n'y a aucune reddition
des comptes et c'est ce qui c'est ce que
les libanais ne veulent plus ils veulent
ils veulent que les que les responsables
n'est pas seulement les avantages du
pouvoir mais aussi la responsabilité
assume la responsabilité qui va avec
dernière question mais très rapidement
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya une nouvelle
conférence internationale pour récolter
voilà une somme d'argent pour venir en
aide à la population est libanaise
évidemment c'est une solution à court
terme mais est ce que finalement la
communauté internationale doit prendre
plus au sérieux peut-être ses
responsabilités envers le liban écoutez
la communauté internationale s'attaque à
ce stade à l'aide d'urgence évidemment
qu'on a besoin de l'aide humanitaire les
est tout de suite tellement d'état est
défaillant et tellement la classe
politique libanaise est incapable de
subvenir ou de répondre aux besoins de
sa population donc l'aide humanitaire
internationale est nécessaire mais mais
là comme et internationale tient un
discours aujourd'hui plus ferme en
disant il n'y aura pas une aide massive
sans des réformes et la responsabilité
revient à la classe politique est
incapable de mener ces réformes tout
simplement parce qu'elle refuse de de
lâcher son pouvoir parce qu'elle est
incompétente qu'elle est corrompu et
qu'elle il s'accroche au pouvoir et
qu'elle est un peu dans une logique de
après moi le déluge tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est rester au pouvoir quitte à
ce que le pays s'effondre et c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer
mais la communauté internationale doit
rester ferme sur cet engagement de dire
non nous vous aiderons pas si vous
n'êtes pas capable de vous aider vous
même merci beaucoup en tout cas ça tarde
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
en direct de beyrouth je rappelle que
vous êtes rédactrice en chef du magazine
économique
le commerce du levant